في تركيا اله المديريه العامه للامن
السواحل عن تعليق مؤقت لحركه الملاحه في
مضيق البوسفور في اسطنبول بسبب جروح سفينه
الشحن
سفينه التي جناحات ابحرت من احد الموانئ
الاوكرانيه باتجاه اسطنبول واكدت انه جرى
ارسال خبراء وقاطرات لانقاذ السفينه
الحركه الان في مضيق البوسفور واين وصلت
الجهود قطر السفينه الجارحه
نعم عبد الصمد انا لا انا ما عم مضيق
البسفور خلفي تماما تقع على السفينه التي
جنحت كما ذكرنا ما زالت حركه المرور في
مضيق البسفور متوقفه بشكل مؤقت الى ان يتم
سحب هذه السفينه ما جرب وان هذه السفينه
في حوالي الساعه السابعه والنصف بالتوقيت
المحلي اصبح اصيبت بعطل في موجه حركه
السفينه مما جعلها تجنح في اتجاه الطرف
الاسيوي من مضيق البسفور الان هناك العديد
من السفن والقاطرات التي تحاول سحب هذه
السفينه في اتجاه وسط المضيق على اعتبار
ان المياه هناك تكون بحله على جانب ال همم
الطرف الاسيوي وبالتالي يقوم يحاولون
سحبها الى وسط المضيق لكي تمكن هذه
السفينه من استكمال طريقها همم التي هي
متجهه اليه عموما همم اخر المعلومات تشير
الى انه لا يوجد اي نتائج اصابات او
اصابات في السفينه السفينه اصلا عبد الصمد
لم تصطدم وانما تمكن قبطانها من ايقافها
قبل الاصطدام وهي الان كما ذكرت لان
المياه ضاحله لا يمكنها التحرك والان تم
محاوله لسحب هذه السفينه الى وسط المضيق
ما زال المضيق متوقف الحركه السير في
المضيق متوقفه مضيق البسفور طبعا عبد
الصمد يشهد الكثير من هذه الحوادث وهذا
ربما دعا همم لحكومه العداله والتنميه في
اكثر من مناسبه للحديث عن ضروره ان شاء
الله قناه موازيه لمضيق البسفور لتخفف
الضغط عن هذا المضيق الذي يمر فيه سنويا
اكثر من 50,000 سفينه سواء من السفن
الداخليه او الخارجيه التي تاتي عبر المدن
التي الدول التي المطله على البحر الاسود
في اتجاه طبعا كما تعلم همم بحر جاء
وبالتالي هي حركه كثيفه للسفن اصلا في
مضيق الاسوار كثير من الحوادث هذه السفينه
طبعا بعد الصمديه قادمه من اوكرانيا ضمن
اتفاقيه الحبوب بتعلم منذ العام الماضي
الاتفاقيه التي وق تونه في اسطنبول
والسفن تتوالى نحو اسطنبول من تحديدا من
موانئ اوديسا في اتجاه مدن العالم وبا
اتجاه تركيا ايضا وبالتالي هذه احدى هذه
السفن هي السفينه شحن طولها 142 متر تحمل
على بلاو وهي جزر في محيط الهادي لا يعلم
حتى الان الى اين بالضبط كانت متوجهه هذه
السفينه لكنها محمله بالمواد الغذائيه
والحبوب من اوكرانيا تعلم طبعا كان همم
وزير الدفاع التركي قد اعلن بانه منذ
بدايه منذ توقيع هذا الاتفاق كان قد تم
شحن واا عبر مضيق البسفور اكثر من سبعه
عشر مليون طن من المواد الغذائيه والحبوب
التي قدمت وتم شحنها من موان اوكرانيا
المختلفه شكرا لك عامر لا في مباراه كبيره
من اسطنبول